[Applause]
hi Ryan yeah whatever
uh The Big Short is about a small group
of outside I gotta ask are you uh are
you you upset with me or are you what's
that you all right you seem upset no man
we're good whatever
all right
uh well
sure
see I was told I was presenting alone so
it's fine you know I mean obviously I've
been recast into some kind of Joe Biden
and Andy Richter Robin type role no it's
fine I'm here for the movie no I'm here
to support you so if you wanna that's no
really there you go take the high road I
look Petty
classic Brad how would you uh how would
you like to move forward well I'd like
to at least read the winner okay we're
we're not announcing the winner there's
not even a winner oh my God Who's Gonna
Be A Winner we're just we're here to
announce the uh the intro yeah oh can I
do that please thank you thank you